In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 3, on which we commemorate the Holy
Hieromater, Antimos of Nicomedia.
On the 3rd of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Hieromater, Antimos, Bishop
of Nicomedia.
Saint Antimos was Bishop of Nicomedia in Bethinia, Asia Minor.
His church was set on fire in the year 288 at the command of the Emperor Maximian and
20,000 Christians perished.
Under the protection of God, Antimos was among those who escaped the conflagration and took
refuge in the surrounding mountains.
He was captured not long after and brought before Maximian, who questioned him amid
all the frightful instruments of torture.
Saint Antimos was unshakable in his confession of faith in Christ.
He suffered many cruel torments and was beaten with rods, made to walk in red-hot bronze
sandals, and finally fixed to a wheel that broke his limbs while the executioners burned
his body with flaming torches.
Strengthened by divine grace, he remained steadfast, and, like gold, refined in the fire, shown
more brightly in the midst of torments.
He prophesied to the Emperor Maximian the approaching end of the pagan empire and the
triumph of Christianity.
The sight of his patience and confidence drove Maximian mad with rage.
He rent his purple cloak and ordered Antimos to be beheaded.
After the saint's death, the hair of his head continued to grow miraculously.
After the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on
us and save us.